oh I feel very rock and roll
I feel very poseur cool hey guys it's
Tuesday when it's Grace's time to talk
back to you let's start over on Twitter
no I changed my mind
tumblr may make new person to person to
person problems don't know when a new
person comments on any of my social
media I praise the crapple then I
welcome them to the it's grace family
how do I know if it's a new person I
don't I guess because what do we really
know in the universe right now talk
amongst yourselves don't bring that to
me maim big more like same dig you the
world this August I'm meeting around 10
Trinity fans in the UK who I've been
speaking to for the past six months I
say this a lot but thank you very
something my drunk kitchen memory for
creating a community that has enabled me
to make lifelong friendships from that's
awesome comments like that really make
mamrie and Hannah and I feel really good
because friendship is cool and meeting
people through the internet that aren't
gonna like perv out on you or physically
harm you it's double cool this is me
giving you a thumbs up Vadra Valley a
new person to person to person
vaudevillian more like call Vivian your
friend she's just been trying to talk to
you and catch up I know I know she tells
the same story over and over again and I
know we don't want to hear about the
important fetus anymore but you really
should call her human boys can't Dakota
shirt spotted on CBS Sunday morning
segment about trans youth devil ha slim
huh that is so [ __ ] cool and that's
all I say about that grace name we are
doing a person person person grace
mamrie Hart or more like gray
fart oat farted at night got full of
shame your boo-boos my heart or heart no
okay it's torn between intense wardo and
heart big fields I've never felt so
conflicted before law okay
there are a lot of feelings you're
having I'm sure but as you get older you
will be conflicted about way more things
that matter like future your personal
life who we want the president to be or
the leader of your country to be give me
a lot of other things in your life that
will conflict' you more than this so
save your worry for like taxes will be
fine now it's good sit down Matt O'Brien
music differents new person-to-person
Matt O'Brien music Mike Matt O'Brien
music mute it unless it's good and good
job you found things in that creative
you found that another way to use your
hands other than diddle Cooper boy if I
hung out with grace up again mametown
for one hour one hour my abs would be
[ __ ] shredded from laughter and your
butthole will be [ __ ] shredded from
all the terrible food we eat and all the
liquor that we consume shredded cheese
stands on shire new person to person to
person stands on shower more like
standing on fire
there's fire let's go boy you could
still be a fire you should get that jock
itch checked out top universe
can you send something to cheer up my
friend she just found out something that
made her really upset please xxxx okay
this is for your friend and for anyone
else out there that's feeling a little
sad or down or disappoint it fart fart
fart fart fart fart fart may see a
marine to person to person to person may
see I'm irate more like may we see Emery
boards for your nails they're gross
fixin your bro
trying to watch Grey's hapax Camp Takota
illegally and it's not working my life
is so hard
I will [ __ ] destroy you you go to
iTunes and you buy that [ __ ] that's not
cool now let's go to youtube stays in
your seat and if you're standing sit
down take a load off everywhere buzz
that's cool public transportation my
phone just went off ex all 13 new purse
new person person X off 30 more like XO
x also teenager oh my god what's your
body feel like like a warping weird
funhouse mirror vision of yourself
puberty is like going through a carnival
funhouse it is not fun uber jokes never
get old they're like Nicole Kidman I
never get old
heavy bob new person to person to person
heady pop more like I'll take two please
and the side of dumplings handy bop hey
bop bip a capita and buck dip fondue you
before Grace's life is the best thing
world peace
I need real love self-respect is also
like kind of the best thing good
frighteners are also like really good
French bulldogs they feel like I
cream without consequence jumping into a
pool really impressively there's a lot
of like really good things out there
that I think probably greater than my
laughs but thank you whattcha new person
to person to person watch it more like
watch out as my Miranda sings
impersonation watch out my uncle
watch out listing boom you need to
change you hair color back okay I'm
waiting for you to say it watch it I'm
gonna change me hair color back I'm not
not even a little bit well that's it for
talking back to you I hope the this was
in I don't know Grace's guide book calm
cool